i recently posted a video on why i
decided to try the keto diet what i'm
eating what i'm not eating including
some things that are often eaten on the
keto diet and i shared with you how i
avoided that dreaded keto flu all
together but at that time it had only
been three weeks into it so today i am
super excited to share with you my one
month results and also let you know that
in that one month i've also been
intermittent fasting with a 16 8 ratio
every single day so whether or not
you're thinking of starting the keto
diet or you just need some motivation
hopefully this will be helpful for you
but just please keep in mind that i'm
not a medical doctor i'm not giving you
any medical advice i'm only sharing with
you my experience so for today's video
i'm going to be sharing with you the 10
changes that i have noticed ever since i
started the keto diet so i won't just be
talking about the waistline even though
i will address that because a majority
of people who start the keto diet really
do so because of its help with weight
loss but i've saved that part for last
for a very specific reason and that is
that if you want to achieve a certain
image and you're willing to do whatever
to get there you may just end up hurting
your body in the process so if you want
to lose weight get toned and have a hot
body well awesome good for you but don't
make that your motivation make your
health and your well-being your
motivation and your priority you have
this incredible piece of machinery that
no one else on earth has
your body so my hope is that you focus
on loving your body throughout the
process and transforming it from inside
out so with that being said if you like
this video and find it helpful please
give it a thumbs up and help support my
channel and if not by all means thumbs
it down but please give me some feedback
in the comments so that i know what to
work on alright let's get started
number one i am so excited about this is
it completely eliminated my eczema rash
i've had eczema ever since i was a kid
and because i've used steroid creams on
and off my skin has now become kind of
discolored hopefully you can see but
it's like spotted in certain areas
because of that long-term use of
steroids and because i've had it for so
long i've known to avoid the use of
steroids at all costs and so i kind of
just for the most part live with dry
itchy skin most of the time and about
two and a half weeks into the keto diet
i was shocked my skin is smooth it
started to smoothen out to where the
rash the redness was kind of going away
but it was becoming smoother and now
presently it is gone to me that's
amazing because i have had dryness and
just at least some degree of a rash
pretty much every day because i try to
avoid the use of those sorts of creams
and no matter what kind of natural
healing creams and ointments i've tried
nothing has completely eliminated the
rash itself so i am super excited about
this change number two is also really
exciting is my hair has changed my hair
is actually softer it's smoother it
doesn't get as frizzy this is my hair
actually post wash just waking up in the
morning i do not own a curler
straightener any of those sorts of
things and i haven't been using any of
products that are different from what i
had normally been using basically i use
an anti-frizz serum and an argan oil and
that's it i did mention in my previous
video that i had been using collagen but
that's not something that has changed
either because i had been doing that
even before i started the keto diet so
maybe you could say that the collagen
made a difference but for me personally
i think that it's been my diet that has
made the most notable change change
number three just continuing on with the
hair and the skin is that my skin is
smoother i noticed that a few weeks in
that my skin just wasn't feeling as
rough it was just feeling a lot softer
even as i applied like makeup i could
definitely tell that it was smoother i
currently use hyaluronic acid every
single day but again that's not
something that's changed i didn't change
that i've been doing that for several
months so i don't think that it would
have been that from before keto to now i
definitely noticed my skin a lot
smoother and change number four i'm
really excited about this one is that
these skin changes are not just on my
face they're kind of all over my body my
arms are softer my skin just in general
is softer and it improved my keratosis
polaris and if you don't know what this
is it's commonly referred to as chicken
skin where basically you have a lot of
bumps that almost seem like pimples it
can be behind the arms in the backs of
the legs the thighs and it's like
sandpaper like if you touch your skin it
feels like sandpaper and it has greatly
improved this in me i unfortunately i
didn't think this was gonna change so i
didn't take like a before shot to be
able to compare but it's definitely a
bonus that my skin does not feel like
sandpaper change number five is totally
tmi you guys we're gonna talk about
bodily functions so if that grosses you
out skip like 15 or 20 seconds okay and
that is that my bowel movements are
superb i have been having about two
regular bowel movements per day and i've
definitely been packing on the veggies
and the fiber but i think that it can
also be because i have been a lot more
strict about remembering to take my
probiotics on a regular basis because
i'm just going to be honest with you i
had been taking them for months but
really forgetting to take them
90 of the time until i did this
challenge because i really wanted to
focus this month on doing everything
that i could that would kind of heal my
body from the inside out and so i was
very strict about taking them so maybe
it's been a mix of the diet with the
probiotics probably both sorry of
talking about poop makes you
uncomfortable but as a nurse i know that
some people are pretty obsessed about
their poops so just figured i'd let you
know and benefit number six is that i
have way more energy and actually i'm
gonna be honest a few days out it
actually went to an extreme where i kind
of had insomnia this was probably when i
would transitioned into ketosis and it
wasn't like i was anxious or worried
about anything it was just i had way too
much energy and so what i did to kind of
get through this hump is that i started
drinking chamomile every single day
before going to bed and just being more
active during the day to kind of burn
that energy off and that definitely
helped i don't feel like i have reversed
back to being as tired i definitely have
a lot more energy and benefit number
seven very similar to the previous one
is that my sleep has improved greatly i
now find that it's a lot easier to
actually fall asleep but then once i am
asleep i don't wake up as often so again
i think that also kind of helps the
waking up in the morning and having more
energy or maybe it's also that because i
have more energy and more active during
the day and then i sleep better at night
i don't know but this is a good cycle
and i'm loving it as a full-time working
mom sleep is delicious
change number eight is a major one for
me and it has reduced my anxiety like a
lot i remember that when i was in high
school i had heard about hyperthyroidism
and i thought how cool these people can
lose weight easy lucky's and i am so
sorry that i ever thought that because
for anybody that has anxiety and isn't
able to control it doesn't know why it
can be crippling i had experienced
anxiety where i would be in the middle
of the night calm happy and i just have
a sensation of anxiety like my heart was
having palpitations i had to kind of
catch my breath kind of as if somebody
was following you and it wasn't that i
was worried it wasn't that i was
thinking about something that was going
on i was happy i have a beautiful family
and one loving husband it's not that i
was anxious it's that my body
felt anxiety and that's a tough feeling
you guys when you have anxiousness and
you don't know why and you can't control
it you don't know why you can't do
anything about it it kind of made me
feel like i was crazy before i had my
diagnosis i didn't realize why this was
happening to me um i haven't had repeat
labs yet it will happen soon but overall
i feel that change in my body i feel a
lot calmer and to me
this is huge
and finally benefits number nine and ten
we will combine together because they're
all about the belly and it's that i have
no bloating i definitely have lost
centimeters off my waistline but also a
major part of that is bloating because
it's kind of the top part of the abdomen
and before trying the keto diet i had
had bloating on a regular basis this is
my before clip i have a one-year-old and
i gained 45 pounds during pregnancy i
lost most of it but i definitely still
had the mommy pooch
initially my waist measured 75 and a
half centimeters
after keto you can see that my top part
of my abdomen is now flat and this is
because i don't have any bloating and
let's be honest my regular bowel
movements probably helped as well
but as far as the weight loss goes my
waist now measures 67 centimeters if i
did my math right then it's a drop in
eight and a half centimeters in one
month i am really proud of myself for
having done keto plus intermittent
fasting for an entire month but if i've
got to be honest with myself of all of
these 10 changes the biggest difference
that it's made in is
my confidence i would say that that's
the hugest
the hugest the biggest change that it
has made because my first postpartum
journey with our daughter i was so mean
to myself i said things to myself that i
would never have said to someone else
and that led me to do things that i
shouldn't have done too early it led me
to actually injure my body and end up in
the hospital because i was over doing it
and even then i was making myself feel
guilty because i couldn't do it fast
enough and that's where i made that
point that if you're trying to get to a
certain goal but you're willing to do
whatever to get there you just may end
up hurting your body which is what i did
and this time around i've been a lot
more patient with myself i've been a lot
kinder to myself and loving my body
throughout all the changes it's
experienced and definitely for anybody
that's experienced pregnancy there's
some major changes the body is never
quite the same and i'm okay with that
and loving myself throughout that
process and just being proud of myself
and my body for all of these changes is
amazing my hope for you is that if
you're doing this mainly for a weight
loss purposes is that you
really try to focus on healing your body
from the inside out focus on that
nutrition and pack on those nutrients
and really become educated on the keto
diet before you try to change anything
that way you won't injure your body or
you won't do anything that will harm
yourself in the process because the goal
really should be your well-being as a
whole i hope that this video has been
helpful for you hopefully it's been a
motivation and any of these changes may
be experienced by you if you try it out
let me know if you've tried it and what
your experience has been and don't
forget to thumbs up and subscribe for
more videos like these thank you so much
i'll see you in the next one bye